[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
gabby petito's death ruled a homicide by
saying that this is a homicide
that is
death at the hands of another forensic
pathologist dr michael baden gives us
his take on the autopsy and r kelly does
not take the stand we head into closing
arguments in the federal trial against
the singer plus the verdict is in
stanley ford is guilty stanley o ford
guilty of the offensive aggravated
murder what sentence the convicted
arsonist could face for nine counts of
murder and later an ex-police officer
headed to trial after the death of a
black texas woman shot through a window
our legal analysts explain what's next
for aaron dean long crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome to law and crime daily i'm
simon choudry in for brian buckmeyer and
with me is co-host terry austin now we
begin with a story gripping the nation a
once missing gabby potito's remains have
been found her death ruled a homicide
meanwhile the search for missing fiance
brian laundry continues in florida with
underwater dive teams now searching the
area laundry was last seen so here's a
bit of a timeline last tuesday laundry
told his family he was backpacking in a
florida reserve on friday laundry's
parents told police they hadn't seen him
in days florida officials then spent the
weekend searching for him well the
search was called off but began again on
tuesday now let's backtrack a little bit
on september 1st laundry returned to his
florida home driving potito's van
without her she was then reported
missing on september 11th ahead of that
now famed body camera footage showed a
domestic incident between the couple
near arches national park potito was
last seen in late august near grand
teton national park in wyoming the teton
county coroner now confirms that the
remains found over the weekend are in
fact gabby petitto her death has been
ruled a homicide but a cause of death
has not yet been released renowned
forensic pathologist dr michael baden
sat down with law and crime network
detailing what most likely happened in
potato's death
likely cause of death in this kind of a
situation is manual strangulation
the mayor a male
stronger than a female pressing on the
neck until
death occurs
other possibilities would be
blunt force trauma to the head with a
rock or an object that causes fractures
and
and hemorrhage in the brain
or shootings or stabbing
meantime potato's father spoke to dr
phil earlier this week saying his
daughter and brian laundry had been
together for two and a half years and
during that time he says he never saw
them fighting
brian was always respectful you know i
can't say he wasn't
what kind of relationship did they have
how would you describe it there's no red
flags that stuck out nothing that popped
in my head that list this boy is you
know it's not a good boy if there were i
would have discouraged going on the trip
well a text message sent from gabby
potito's phone could offer clues as to
when she died as angenette levy tells us
petito's mom described the text as odd
the information about this text message
came from an affidavit that police used
to get a search warrant for the hard
drive that was found in gabby potito's
van
so me and brian just got up and got
ready
made the bed in the tent
set up gabby petito recorded much of her
cross-country travels with brian laundry
the video possibly stored on a hard
drive found in her van a detective wrote
in an application for a search warrant
for the hard drive that gabby's mother
nicole schmidt had several conversations
with her daughter during the trip and
that there appeared to be more and more
tension between gabby and laundry the
detective also wrote that gabby's mother
received an odd text on august 27th from
gabby's number stating can you help stan
i just keep getting his voicemails and
missed calls schmidt's mother told
detectives stan was gabby's grandfather
and she never called him by his name
which concerned her it was the last time
anyone heard from gabby
interestingly enough the text came the
same day the bethune family's camera
recorded a white van that appears to be
gabby's in the spread creek dispersed
campground near the area where gabby's
body was found the detective goes on to
write that gabby potito's white van
entered the city of northport florida on
september 1st
gabby petito was reported missing 10
days later on september 11th
investigators are likely sifting through
all of the data on that hard drive to
see whether it yields any clues about
gabby potito's death and disappearance
for law and crime daily i'm angenette
levy
thanks angenet joining us now are terry
austin and trial attorney jeff storms
let's start with jeff jeff officials in
florida they're still searching for
missing fiance brian laundry what can we
expect in terms of any charges when he's
found
well you know at this point in time we
still don't know what the cause of death
was
and so obviously if it was something
like blunt force trauma and there's a
link um you know
what the intent was we don't know
uh but we would obviously expect the
potential for some sort of manslaughter
or murder charge depending on what they
find
but dr baden who i've had the pleasure
working with on numerous occasions you
know points out the likely uh causes of
death and what i find interesting is
that they are being relatively quiet
even on potential causes which leads me
to believe that they want to maintain a
certain level of secrecy to aid them in
their investigation uh and ultimate
criminal charges
well let me ask terry a question that so
many people have been asking about on
social media the case of gabby potito
has garnered substantial media attention
but some believe that's not enough
attention is being paid to missing or
murdered indigenous women and women of
color what are your thoughts on this
issue well i think that's probably right
i mean obviously every case every
missing person every murdered person
should be investigated thoroughly but
there was a task force formed to
investigate how many indigenous people
are
really looked after when they are
missing or when they are murdered and
the numbers don't lie the numbers are
showing that even though there are more
indigenous people who are murdered they
are not covered in the media so
we really do need to make sure that it's
equal representation and that we're
looking for everyone
absolutely terry of course we're going
to continue following this uh
developments in the gabby potito case
but we do want to move on because we
have so much to cover here in long crime
daily and still ahead the verdict well
that's in for stanley ford and he's
found guilty what a sentence could look
like for the ohio man convicted of
setting deadly fires in his neighborhood
but first r kelly does not take the
stand we head to federal court where the
r b singer's trial could soon have a
verdict
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to lawn crime daily now new
information in the federal trial of r
kelly the singer will not testify in his
trial r kelly is charged with a slew of
sex crime charges including sex
trafficking and racketeering the defense
wrapped a wednesday morning marking an
end to nearly one month of testimony
we're talking about 45 witnesses
testifying for the prosecution with only
five testifying for the defense the r b
singer chose not to testify in his own
defense closing arguments began
wednesday afternoon now let's bring back
jeff storm and co-host terry austin jeff
in a federal case such as this what can
we expect as far as closing arguments
and verdict watch is it possible we
could have a verdict by the end of the
week
well i i think it's entirely possible it
sounds like the closings will wrap up
likely tomorrow i i think they're either
ongoing or ending just as we're getting
on air today
and i think given the slew of evidence
that we've seen in this case which was
cleverly put forward through a
racketeering rather than an individual
charge it would not surprise me for a
very frankly very fast guilty verdict
yeah by the end of the week
and terry r kelly did not testify so do
you think with proper preparation it
would have been beneficial if he had
taken the stand i don't think so any
amount of preparation i think still
would not have him prepared for this
trial because he would be subject to
cross-examination and he would have to
defend his actions and many of the
victims testified that he sexually
abused them that he was violent he would
have to explain on cross-examination how
he
explained himself in terms of
transmitting diseases to women and
knowingly doing that so i think it would
be very difficult for him to get up on
that stand and we've seen him in other
interviews obviously where he's lost his
temper and if that happened on the stand
that would be the death knell for the
trial for him because the jury would see
him getting angry and that was part of
the testimony here that he had a temper
so
best to keep him off the stand terry
speaking of
emotions had he been emotional and
regretful could that have been
beneficial it could have been but it
would be hard to get him to that point i
think okay all right let's talk about
another high profile case we have an
update now on a story we first brought
to you earlier this week defense
attorneys well they say harvey weinstein
is healthy enough to appear in court for
an upcoming trial
on monday weinstein pleaded not guilty
to grand jury indictments of sexual
assault and battery in california
after the arraignment weinstein's
lawyers commented that he can't walk and
he can't see
david ring the california attorney who
represents him
accuser jane doe one says the disgraced
film producer should be capable of
appearing in court
uh i haven't heard he has coveted or
anything like that so uh as far as i
know he is in he's in shape where if
they get this trial off
and running in the next six months
there's no no reason at all why he
shouldn't be present at that trial
all right so of course we're going to be
following that but there's still so much
to come here on law and crime daily
we're talking about the next steps for
the cop who pulled the trigger on dante
wright plus a verdict has been reached
in ohio for the arson murder trial of
stanley ford what the jury had to say
that's next
[Music]
verdict form count two aggravated murder
we the jury find the defendant stanley o
ford stanley o ford guilty of the
offensive aggravated murder in the
charges um in the indictment occurring
on the 15th day of may 2017.
we have a verdict in ohio for stanley
ford's arson murder trial after
deliberating for close to 14 hours the
jury found stanley ford guilty of
setting the two house fires that killed
nine people the charges included
aggravated murder and aggravated arson
the jury found ford not guilty of a
third fire that was set to a parked car
that had no casualties testimony lasted
nine days and the defense called no
witnesses and the defendant did not take
the stand the death penalty phase is set
to begin on monday september 27th let's
bring back terry and jeff terry let me
start with you there are nine people who
died in this case including the youngest
there was children involved the youngest
was just the toddler uh how how is
how is how is it going to look moving
forward when it comes to when the jury
has to look at what he is now really
found guilty of well this is definitely
a death penalty case nine people and as
you so point out children in fact some
of them were found under the father and
that is just a horrible situation
whether you believe in the death penalty
or not one of the things you have to be
certain about is this is the person who
committed this crime there was some
doubt i guess there was not reasonable
doubt as far as the jury was concerned
and the doubt here was there was another
suspect who set an earlier fire but he
was dismissed as being responsible for
either one of those fires and the other
issue here is the video wasn't exactly
clear that it was stanley ford although
they had a lot of other evidence so
the death penalty this is the type of
case whether or not it's a million
percent i'm not certain
jeff do you think there's any way that
he might not get the death penalty maybe
face something uh
lesser uh it's entirely possible but i
think more likely than not there is a
death penalty finding here however the
state of ohio has several serial killers
sitting on death row for a number of
years now so whether or not
he is actually put to death i think
becomes a little less likely giving the
appeals and whatnot
yeah this is such a difficult case i
mean i know i was listening to the
witnesses and then when you think about
the children involved it really it does
it does hurt your heart to hear this
case again the um
this picks up on september 27th now
again we have so much more we are going
to switch gears again and now we're on
to day two of jury selection and the
trial of the united states airmen
accused of killing a mennonite sunday
school teacher mark gooch is accused of
killing
27-year-old sasha krauss who disappeared
from her community in january of 2020.
her remains were found over a month
later an autopsy revealed she died of
blunt force trauma and a gunshot wound
to the head well cell phone records and
surveillance video put gooch at the
scene of the crime previous cell phone
records obtained to show that gooch and
his brothers show contempt towards those
in the mennonite faith mark gooch is
charged with first degree murder and
faces life in prison if found guilty
now for gavel to gavel live coverage of
the trial tune into law in crime network
and when we come back kim potter's
defense team wants this newly upgraded
charge dismissed what lies ahead for the
ex-cop charged with the killing of dante
wright
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily we
look now to minnesota where the
attorneys representing kim potter
request a dismissal in her recently
added first degree manslaughter charge
to her case
the former minnesota police officer is
charged with fatally shooting dante
wright during a routine traffic stop in
april of 2021
during that stop potter discharged her
gun allegedly thinking it was her taser
well she shot the 20-year-old before he
sped away and he later died
wright's death along with those of
george floyd and philando castile
sparked outrage across the country after
all three black men were shot and killed
by minnesota police officers the
minnesota attorney general added
potter's first degree manslaughter
charge earlier this month which has a
maximum sentence of 15 years potter's
attorneys filed a motion on wednesday to
dismiss this upgraded charge
back with us is civil rights attorney
jeff storms who represents dante
wright's family so jeff what sort of
reaction are we seeing from the wright
family
well i mean i think that uh repeatedly
the family has felt like they're going
to be efforts by
officer potter to dodge responsibility
for her actions
and you know this would be another clear
example
of that you know the family was very
vocal in uh saying that you know they
wanted to see murder charges
and so the concept that officer potter
would attempt to avoid a trial
on an upgraded manslaughter charge you
know it is just frankly somewhat
appalling to the family
well how is the family dealing with this
i'm sure it's been an obvious emotional
rollercoaster especially knowing that
this now former cop is saying that this
was some sort of accident
yeah you know
a lot of my professional time is spent
working with families like the rights
who have lost someone they love due to
government misconduct whether it's the
police or other agencies and
what i what i tell people when i lecture
on this issue is that i don't know why
but the families that lose loved ones in
this manner
seem to struggle so much more
than my families who lose their loved
ones and other manners of death so you
know the family has obviously been
struggling
as they've gone through this process and
will continue to be frustrated by
anything that looks like an effort to
avoid responsibility
all right thank you so much jeff we're
going to continue to follow this case
turning now to texas where the trial
date is now set for a former police
officer charged in the 2019 murder of a
black woman aaron dean is charged with
the shooting death of a tatiana
jefferson during a welfare check in
november of 2019. jefferson was
babysitting her eight-year-old nephew
when a neighbor made a non-emergency
9-1-1 call saying the door was open
well dean entered through the backyard
and shot jefferson through the window
after claiming to have seen a gun
pointed at him
multiple lawsuits have been filed in
relation to her death including one
stating jefferson's nephew has suffered
extreme and severe mental distress for
witnessing his aunt's murder while the
trial is set to start on november 16th
and terry aaron dean was charged with
murder in connection with the death of a
tatiana jefferson do you think that's
the right charge in this case i do think
it's the right charge but i think also
that there should be additional charges
oftentimes the prosecution will put the
lesser charge in just in case the jury
doesn't reach a verdict and in texas
murder is intentional and knowingly and
perhaps the argument from the defense
will be this was reckless this wasn't
intentional and so therefore perhaps the
prosecution should include a
manslaughter charge which would be the
reckless
standard there so i think that it makes
sense to charge with murder i think
there's enough here to say that there
was a murder but i think it makes sense
to in fact put the manslaughter charge
in there just in case the jury gets to
that point
well you know we've been talking about
cops making alleged allegedly making
mistakes in cases like this all across
the country do you think that has any
influence during trial i do think it has
influenced doing trial and i think it
has influence as far as the charges are
concerned here we see the murder charge
and that is the higher charge and i
think the prosecution is taking its cue
from what's going on across the country
and so i think that's why they started
out with that high charge but again i
think they should include that
manslaughter
and again that trial is set to start on
november 16th i want to thank you to
terry austin and jeff storms and thank
you so much for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you